my name is dr. Ramsay Rosa and for the
last decade I've spent my life dedicated
to a single course helping others fight
the diseases that plague humanity
but not anymore and it's all because of
them you see there are many cancers in
this world and they all wear different
faces some are doctors like me some of
them seek out the truth regardless of
the consequences
others mock the very science they
worship or just ran out of time why is
it every time I come to visit there's
always a crisis how intersect the
scientifically impossible will happen
underneath understand them just tell me
what I can do
[Music]
hey everybody is Charlie they dropped a
brand new promo for the flash season 6
episode 1 and there's a whole bunch of
DC stuff that just happened the last
week Tyler hoechlin is talking about the
supposed Superman spin-off TV show
that's been in development for forever
we have more Joker movie footage coming
up a birds-of-prey trailer and I had a
chance to see Titans Season 2 episode 1
so all add a little non spoilery review
for that at the end of this video with
no spoilers just because everybody have
to wait a couple days to actually watch
it we'll do any round of the giveaway
for the DC streaming service all you
have to do to enter is be subscriber and
leave your best crisis on Infinite
Earths theory on the video first big
thing - if you guys didn't notice they
brought back the chin strap they dropped
this preview and everyone's like oh my
god welcome back chin strap we missed
you so much
I cannot remember a video that I posted
last year where there weren't people
complaining about the lack of a chin
strap the costume itself is slowly
moving in a more comic-book direction so
they're getting there but the way they
film the show and the special effects
all in combination with the way Grant
Gustin moves through physical space just
wound up looking kind of awkward without
the chin strap like it didn't look
better than previous versions of the
costume and then when Stephen Amell wore
the costume it wasn't quite as
flattering as it could have been because
he's like a really huge dude but the
costume did not do him any favors so
everyone rejoiced the chin strap is back
and that's also part of the crisis news
paper because this whole time in the
crisis newspaper going back to season 1
he's always had a chin strap so people
are just wondering when we're gonna see
that version of the costume so here it
is the official flash crisis on Infinite
Earths costume
first things first new flash footage the
flash showrunner talking about there are
three different story arcs and the
different villains they're going to have
this season the big changes is that the
first half of the season right before
crisis is gonna be the blood work
villain this mostly featured in this
episode one trailer Ramsey Rosa is a
comic book character if you haven't read
the flash rebirth he's right out of that
but he's a relatively minor character
who was working inside the CCPD with
Barry Allen during the negative flash
art so he had a special personal history
with Barry Allen but on the TV show
that'll be with Caitlin because he's a
scientist she's a scientist so they'll
have previously worked together
his main metahuman ability is
controlling
blood literally controlling blood he can
create constructs he can control the
blood and other people he can control
the Flash's blood even though it's laced
with Speed Force energy the showrunner
said that his storyline is building up
to crisis on Infinite Earths even though
all the episodes the first half of the
season on the flash arrow the other DC
TV shows will set up crisis in different
ways
great Gustin said that they start
teasing crises right away in the first
episode the monitor shows up and gives
him the business that he gave to all of
her at the end of last season they
didn't say how long they're gonna wait
before they actually physically reveal
the anti-monitor but this is what he
looks like he's basically a dark version
of the monitor which makes more sense
than going with a more literal
adaptation from the comics just because
he looks so crazy but I don't know how
much they're gonna get into the idea of
who he used to be before he became the
anti-monitor they have way more story to
play with than you would during a normal
two-hour movie so just expect more
backstory into what's going on with the
anti-monitor his fight with buried
directly sets up what happens at the
beginning of the crossover but that also
is because of Harrison wells so there's
a new version of Harrison wells coming
but Tom Cavanaugh is also playing
another pariah character from the comics
who in the name of simplicity and logic
will probably just look like an
alternate version of Harrison wells from
a different earth in the multiverse any
time Tom Cavanagh pops up multiple times
in an episode is usually just different
versions of Harrison wells the pariah
character will wind up serving the
anti-monitor and be the person that tips
off the crossover I've talked a little
about this in previous videos the pariah
character in the comics is a totally
different person but he's the person
responsible for alerting the
anti-monitor to the existence of the
positive matter multiverse his
scientific experiments doomed them all
and then he winds up being cursed to
serve the anti-monitor and serve as a
warning trying to run around the
multiverse telling everyone he's coming
to destroy everything you're all gonna
die the way they talked about him they
also made it sound like pariah is
different from the reverse-flash that
you Bart Thawne reverse-flash who's also
coming back for crisis on Infinite
Earths so technically that's three
different characters the Tom Cavanagh is
playing all the stuff the first couple
of episodes pretty standard setting up
the brand new characters the new version
of Harrison wells on the team and they
did say did this new Harrison wells
storyline will be very specific to how
crisis on Infinite Earths go down so if
you're looking for actual teasers for
crisis on Infinite Earths just watch his
character in what he does during
episodes because he in his pariah
counterpart are more important than ever
in beginning the actual crossover
episodes most of what's going on with
Barrie at the beginning of the season is
just leftover grief from Nora at the end
of last season because it's not a whole
lot of time has gone by when episode 1
picks up so they're still reeling from
watching her die seemingly die because
remember what happened when speedsters
die their body turns into pure energy
going back into the Speed Force so
because of the timeline edits a new
version of Nora will eventually come
along I imagine at some point some of
that will get teased during crisis on
Infinite Earths and then they'll pay it
off by the end of season 6 but I don't
expect Nora to come right back on the
show right after they kill her off but a
new version of her will come along
eventually and the showrunner also did
say that a lot of what's going on the
first half of the season will be
callbacks to the stuff that they did
during the Elseworlds crossover so he's
like you better watch the Elseworlds
crossover episodes again if you want to
know what's going on I think when he's
talking about that he's talking about
all the monitor scenes where he's
setting up the larger crisis does it
play the bargain that he makes with
Oliver that kind of stuff I've already
talked about a lot of the other big
characters they're bringing on probably
one of the biggest being Kevin Conroy
older Batman from the Batman Beyond
continuity and Batman the Animated
Series bringing that into canon with the
arrowverse like they try to slowly bring
in the small Bell stuff Tom Welling and
Michael Rosenbaum were at a panel
recently talking about the Smallville
version of Batman that they tried to do
way back in the day people of course
asked them about appearing during the
crossover and they claimed that no one
has contacted them with an offer about
crossing over but I think that's them
just messing with the fans because Tom
Welling has been messing with people
about being in the crossover for most of
the year since it was announced the
other big thing that's happening during
the crossover this year is that they're
setting up another spin-off TV show that
the CW is developing for the arrow purse
they didn't say what it was going to be
there are a couple of big options the
way they talk about it to make it sound
like it's an
going to be a direct spinoff of arrow
with those future team arrow characters
like Mia and her team around her people
have been asking Tyler hoechlin this
whole time because they spent so much
time developing his character his baby
John Kent with his Lois Lane in last
year's crossover seemed sort of like a
backdoor pilot if he was going to do his
own spin-off Superman TV show what he
said was is that he feels like a show
with just him would be kind of boring
but I think winking behind the camera
the whole idea was is that they spent so
much time developing the idea that he
was having a baby with Lois Lane and
they were gonna get married that the
show might be more about him raising
that young boy Jon Kent with Lois Lane
because that's something that they've
never done on the TV shows before like
they've done Superman TV shows in the
past we're almost on the 10-year
anniversary of Smallville that was him
in high school and in his very first
years so when they do new shows with
characters that they've already done
they try to do it in a way that they've
never done before and Superman family
with Superboy is something that has
never been done on TV it's probably
gonna be next spring before we actually
find out what the new show is going to
be so let me know in the comments which
new TV show do you want the DC TV people
to do and because I had a chance to see
Titan season 2 episode 1 here's my quick
non-spoilery review I'll do a bigger
Easter egg video this weekend the first
chunk of the episode drags completely as
they try to take the show in a new
direction and you can physically feel
when all the new season 2 stuff starts
picking up it feels like a real Teen
Titans TV show a thousand times better
than what they were doing during season
1 but what happened is is that they had
a finale last year that they shot and
then canceled didn't air it then chopped
it up and turned it into part of their
episode 1 to wrap up their trigon arc so
all the stuff that doesn't work in
episode 1 is that leftover trigon stuff
from the end of last season then if
you've seen the titan season 2 trailer
the second part of the episode is where
they sort of split the group up and set
up the brand new characters in this word
feels a thousand times better the
dialogue the character interactions the
actual characters that they're bringing
on during season 2 also much better than
what they were doing with season 1 so if
you didn't watch titan season 1 because
you didn't like what they were doing you
could just sweep that
to the rug and start fresh with season 2
episode 1 brand-new episodes start
airing tomorrow there's 13 episodes I
believe in season 2 so however you can
find a way to watch the show and just
leave all your video requests as we go
along week to week I've got new birds of
prey and new Joker movie videos coming
up so I'll name a giveaway winner when I
post those everybody click here to watch
that new birds of prey trailer and click
here for my non-spoiler e joker movie
review thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight
you